well this is a profound question because
news today exists in a climate of
abundance whereas before it was sort of
a scarcity model and what I do is follow
certain people & blogs and sites that
are actually monitoring a much wider
range of sources than I am and so I
delegate the work of finding the
important news to expert filters
intelligent people who are doing just
that because this is a basic way of
creating value on the net so people ask
me all the time about information
overload and isn't it all too much and
oh you know this new age of information
is turning into a disaster and I meet
with this kind of hysteria all the time
but actually if you know who to follow
and you know where to look you can
easily profit and benefit from this
abundance because the tools for
organizing information follow right
behind the explosion of information that
the net represents well the example you
gave was actually someone giving credit
to an aggregator for something that
appeared at that site maybe they
shouldn't do that but let's go back to
what an aggregator is what is Matt
Drudge what is the Drudge Report it's
simply a guy in his apartment finding
first new reports that have been posted
on the web and collecting those that
would be interesting to his audience in
one place that's all he's doing scanning
the web for what's new different and
interesting now this is something that
if the major news media had decided to
specialize in it they could have been
very good and from the beginning they
chose
to do that why because in order to be
Matt Drudge or The Huffington Post or
real clear politics or any number of
bloggers who link constantly to stuff
you have to do exactly that send people
away from your site transport them to
another domain and the news industry
which moans about aggregation didn't
want to develop that art and chose not
to and in fact to this day most of the
major news sites don't link out very
often or very willingly so don't
complain about Drudge if you decided to
turn down the art of aggregation and
don't bitch and moan about Google News
if you don't understand how it works and
why it's really a boon for you to be
send all that traffic
you